i appreciated amino hassan going out to
milwaukee and sitting in the dunk tank
did you guys see this
i did a friend of mean who said the
bucks were the worst finals team ever
said some crazy hot takes about the
bucks at a time when they were down two
nothing and
brooke lopez on isolations was the story
of the finals
they looked terrible things changed and
that's the way the ball bounces but i
mean to his credit i went out to
milwaukee and sat in a dunk tank and i
saw a video where he realized
during this this experience that drunk
amine in the dunk tank
was not a good idea how you doing amin
how was your experience in milwaukee
thanks for joining the rich eisen show
milwaukee was awesome what a lovely
uh city lovely citizenry but
uh i'm still icing my tailbone because
no one told me that when you're in a
dump tank
it's not that deep so when you fall
yes you're being submerged but you're
also smashing
your tailbone against the bottom of the
tank over and
over and over again um
yeah it doesn't sound like a good time
man um and but i would imagine it was a
lot of fun for those bucks fans who got
a chance to see you
out there and they are flying high in
milwaukee obviously
and that's kind of the the sentiment is
what why bobby portis stayed it's just
because he had so much fun
that was kind of one of the surprising
deals yesterday getting him on the cheap
yeah it wasn't just getting him on the
cheap is that he had confirmed
offers worth more money elsewhere and he
turned it down and i you know i thought
that the whole point of the exercise of
taking less money to come to milwaukee
in the first place
was to do exactly what he did play
meaningful minutes on a high profile
team and if you're lucky
help them win a championship and bobby
did that to a t matter of fact
i would say he had the second best game
of any of the milwaukee bucks
in that game six clinching victory uh so
he had the work world in his
palm as far as being able to command
big money to make up for the discount
that he gave the boxes last year
instead he said hey i'll take your text
to the mid-level and that
that'll be that yesterday i'm in a
coffee spot here on the west side in los
angeles and it's 301 302 and i'm like
why
why are they still open why are they
still servicing people
uh you know the whole world stops an mba
free agency and i'm getting wi-fi and
i'm watching you live
on the dan lebotard show's youtube
channel breaking down free agency
but then my coffee order came up and i
had to put the phone away and get in the
car
what move were you most excited for
yesterday i mean
excited you know they're all exciting to
me i guess but
i i thought mike conley staying in utah
for the number that he got was a huge
coup for the utah jazz
you know we talk about small market
teams like utah
as places that hey you guys have to
overpay for your talent
but in the case of mike conley if we
look at the four best point guards who
are on the market
chris paul 120 over four years kyle
lowry 90 million over three years
lonzo ball 85 million over four years
for them to get conley
at a discount you know despite there not
being any other
point guards available on the market we
know there's still teams that need
point guard help i thought that was a
tremendous coup
for the utah jazz to keep him and to cut
their payroll
and indeed it's allowed them to go ahead
and come to terms with rudy gate of the
day
uh for their taxpayer mid-level i think
utah really helped themselves
tremendously with
this all season i mean as a knicks fan
let me just tell you point guard's kind
of overrated in today's nba let me just
yeah
look at like a fan of a team that
doesn't have a point guard like i said
we'll figure it out later on down the
road um
some teams that upgraded their back core
one of those teams was was chicago
that was the first big announcement was
that lonzo was heading up to chicago
being joined by caruso getting the
backcourt back together
laker fans all in their feelings on
twitter which we love
what were your thoughts on the caruso
signing pairing him up with lonzo in
chicago
well you know with caruso we were expect
that again this is a guy who played for
modest money
first few years of his career he was a
two-way player if you remember
and then he signed a two-year deal and
now he gets to go out there and
and sign actual real deal big money
he was a great contributor for the
lakers over his tenure and i think he
deserves it
now uh lonzo ball obviously he gets to
back up his
former teammate lonzo again as i said he
was you know
probably the fourth best point guard on
the market after paul lowry
and conley and that's saying that's
saying a lot i think he's
really developed into a nice player can
those guys help chicago
yes is are those the moves that i think
are going to take chicago
from a team languishing outside of the
play-in
to a top five or top six
team i'm not so sure i still have
questions about them defensively
um and i think that this is a team
that really needs to figure out its
identity before i can feel confident
about
chicago being quote unquote fixed mino
hassan joins the show
you know him from meadowlark media the
milwaukee dunk tank
and from the cinephobe podcast yesterday
on the show
uh we had karl ravichon i mean and
carl said that at one moment in his life
he took his family to see norbit and
they walked out of the theater they were
so disgusted
by eddie murphy tandy newton cuba
gooding jr that carl ravaged said to his
family
we got to walk out of this and i said to
him yesterday norbit would be a good
film to select and to talk about on
cinephobe have you guys done an orbit
episode and would you be interested in
having carl on
we have not done norbert yet eddie
murphy month
is coming right now we just started
rom-com
and so uh our first submission there is
the 2001
jack black season uh jason biggs movie
shaving silverman uh also with
amanda pete is in that movie as well so
that comes out tomorrow
eddie murphy month is on the way and man
if you could send me carl ravitch's
contact
for that that would be lovely i'd love
to ask him why would you take your
family to go norfolk that does not look
like a family movie at
all i just don't understand
the thought process for karl ravich who
is one of the more accomplished
broadcasters covering baseball for years
and the worldwide leader
what did he expect from norbit i had so
many unanswered questions yesterday so
hopefully he can jump on your pod and
you guys can figure him out
when was that time you walked out of a
of a movie i mean
i've never walked out of a movie in my
life i've fallen asleep
in many a movie many many a movie uh but
in terms of if i paid money and i walked
into a movie theater to watch a movie
no matter how awful and i do believe i
did see norbert in the theater
i would not walk out of the theater i
watched the adventures of pluto nash
in the theater i watched water world
opening weekend
in the theater i'm look i'm i'm that guy
if i if we paid money to come see this
we're gonna see this even if it's
painful
i saw pluto nash with my dad and louise
guzman saved the movie for us that's
something we
always have together it's louise
guzman's performance
in pluto nash amino hassan joins the
show uh
getting back to the world of nba free
agency tell me why the evan fournier
signing was the steal of the day
stealing today i'm not gonna call it the
steal of the day
you know a lot of teams i would say
around the league this is one of these
most sane free agencies we've ever had i
think
it's one of those ones where i look
around every team like yeah that's
actually pretty good i think that could
help you
now can it help you to the extent that
you think
uh probably not i think you're still
looking for more when it comes to
evan forney and you look at what they
paid them
there's a part of me that says but i
could have had reggie bullock for
half as much and still had money left
over to answer
other needs am i saying that evan reggie
bullock and everypony are the same type
of player
no obviously having fornia is a better
more skilled player
all i'm saying is i think he's not twice
as good as reggie bullock and if you
kept reggie bullock at the number that
he got from dallas
you still had money left over to play to
go get some
other stuff done whether it's to sign
someone else or maybe decide to trade
for someone
into that uh cap space that you have or
that flexibility that you have
so i i wasn't it's not that evan 20 is a
bad pick up it's not even that evan pony
is overpaid i'm just saying that for
what the knicks needed
i think there were more efficient ways
to use their money than spending it on
inventory
well he just cooked the united states in
the olympics so i'm all in on evan
pointier obviously
um i mean let's talk about my other my
my real favorite player carmelo anthony
you think he comes to the lakers and did
the lakers do enough to surround their
new big three
to make a real run in the west yeah so
the
last couple of years i thought portland
had become the perfect landing spot for
him
it was he had readjusted his game and
became more
effective in smaller pockets and smaller
windows uh they obviously afford him
like the respect level that he was
looking for as a future hall of famer
uh and it kind of all worked out but the
blazers as you see
it's kind of iffy right now is game
staying as being leaving
even if he stays even if everyone's fine
team's
okay but it's not great you got an
opportunity to go play with
your best friend in lebron james and
obviously a
really talented supporting cat with russ
and anthony davis
uh you get to take what you learned in
portland as far as those small windows
of effectiveness and bring it to la uh
where i'm sure
uh he's got family and it's a lot more
convenient for him
and you know the lakers are a team
that's expected to compete for a
championship
if carmelo doesn't go to la which would
be on the minimum
it would have to be because someone
somewhere else offered him
a bigger money and a bigger role but i
think at this stage of his career
this is kind this this is what it was
meant to be right him and lebron one
last time
oh man when you put it like that you
have me all my feelings i mean i think i
might go out and
go to fanatics and get me a lake of
carmelo lakers jersey can you imagine me
walking down hollywood boulevard carmelo
lakers jersey
oh man go lakers huh
what color would you get it gold purple
white black it's got too many colors now
they they do right i think that the nba
has gone a little crazy with their
colors and the lakers do have too many
options but a carmelo anthony number
seven lakers jersey might be in my
future and i can't believe i'm actually
saying that amino hassan joins the show
you know i'm of course from meadowlark
media ben lyon's in for rich on the rich
eisen show
it's interesting the united states team
is going to play australia australia
still has some
uh free agents of their own in terms of
the nba patty mills and dante exum
without deals patty mills is a guy that
everybody is talking about on day two
of free agency where do you see patty
going
yeah this one's really interesting
because obviously he's
despite his advanced stage at this point
it's hard to remember he was
a second round pick in 2008 as a
as a four-year player at saint mary's
and here
he is uh 13 years later and he's still
doing the damn thing and he's definitely
doing the damn thing
in the olympics and for patty mills some
might say oh wait how's he still on sign
well we know paddy mills plays great in
the olympics and
what better infomercial for your
services than playing great on a world
stage
and so he gets to come back if you guys
see what i did over there
i can help your team as far as where
he's gonna go and that's an interesting
one because again
i think there are a lot of options out
there as far as teams needing offense
off the bench
and i think patty himself has a decision
to make
of do i want the highest bidder or do i
want to go somewhere where we're going
to have a chance to
uh contribute to winning uh and you know
depending on what that answer is i think
it could be any number of destinations
for them
you know a guy i had my eyes on for the
knicks who ultimately went to new
orleans was devante graham
new orleans losing lonzo ball bringing
in graham how do you think this helps
them
in their process which they're on the
clock now for recruiting zion to
to stay cause part of me thinks he has
one foot out the door already
yeah it's tough i mean like new orleans
i won't lie you know i said most of the
teams kind of did stuff that made sense
i think new orleans signing devonta
grant to that money was a little bit of
a head scratcher
i don't know i mean they did that trade
trading
for volunteerness to open up some
flexibility
presumably to go after a big fish to you
know kind of
complete the threesome of zion brandon
ingram and
you know whoever the third guy is going
to be um
or at the very least have the
flexibility keep lonzo ball who
obviously
developed a nice little chemistry with
zion and really neither of those things
happened your big move was to go get
devante graham who was
a nice decent player for charlotte but
obviously had his ads his limitations
and
became uh imminently expendable as soon
as
uh uh lamelo ball came on the scene
you know i look if it weren't for this
crazy pressure that they created for
themselves
to be awesome right away uh i would say
that's a nice little move you start but
you keep building you're moving in the
right direction
but when you fire two head coaches in
two years and you know
you're doing all these deals and and
kind of everything's constantly shifting
there is a pressure now for new orleans
to be successful successful isn't
make the play in tournaments successful
for them they need to make the playoffs
uh because here's the deal everyone
talks about no one turning down
a max extension off their rookie scale
so it's kind of like fit to complete
like oh this guy's staying no problem
don't worry about it until the second
deal
but if you're zion williamson and you
can get traded
before your extension's up that is a
massive
massive tip for him because it allows
you to continue to get
those super max designations down the
line on your second and third deals
if you get traded in the first four
years of your career it's the same thing
that christopher zingas went through in
new york
when he forced his way out before his
rookie extension
in the trade that ultimately brought the
knicks cle anthony early amino hassan
joins the show
ben line's filling in for rich on the
rich eisen show
and uh no i actually you know i stand
corrected i'm sorry i mean
the knicks traded for clay anthony early
in the tyson chandler trade
i apologize i need to be better when i'm
on with you dennis smith jr
is a good okay thank you yeah yeah it's
so many memories um
uh i mean it's been 25 years since the
96 draft i did an article
in a slam anniversary issue profiling
john wallace who was part of that
draft class and john said something kind
of interesting to me with some life
perspective now and that
he did something that's really hard to
do he made the nba he did something
that's
almost harder to do he got kind of
pushed out of the nba played overseas
and played his way back
into the nba we just saw today that sam
decker wisconsin star in college
bounced around the nba played overseas
now for two years
signed a deal with the toronto raptors
how hard is that for players to do
to be pushed out of the league play
overseas a few years and then play their
way back into the nba
yeah it's different it's different for
every guy by the way i was at the 96
draft i was in high school and i went
with my cousin
uh and we saw the whole thing from like
the family seats not in the green room
but like
the family section right off the sides
of the green room um
but for a guy like sam dekker what
happened to him
wasn't it wasn't like what happened to
cameron payne
people legitimately ask is cameron payne
an nba player
and he went to china and that was
supposed to be it and then he gets a
call and says hey can you come to the
bubble
we need a backup point guard place
decently to say you want to come back
next year come back next year
plays really well this year especially
in the playoffs and
ends up with a now a multi-year deal
that he got from the sun
albeit a very very undervalued one i
thought he could get a lot more
especially when you look at what other
backup point guard
like tj mcconnell got sam dekker was a
guy who played he was a rotation nba
player
his deal came up and he took a
better financial offer overseas i
believe he went to turkey
he could have stayed in the nba i'm not
saying he would have made a lot of money
doing it
uh he probably would have been a minimum
player or somewhere around there a lower
exception type player
uh and he probably would have to bounce
around a little bit before he found the
right situation
uh so over the last two years he
probably maximized his money by going
overseas going back
to europe to make up that money but it's
not like a case where people
question is sam dekker nba equality
because i think we all felt he was a
rotation caliber players just
hey man there wasn't a whole lot of job
security at the time
appreciate the insight as always and for
spending some time and i hope to uh get
karl ravitch on your nor bit podcast
soon
yeah i can't wait to see what gets
aggregated makes everyone go mad and
angry
about something i said on this show oh
wait what do you mean like last time
when you said that monty williams was a
terrible person what are you talking
about
yeah no yeah isn't that fun how like i
just slammed i love this thing
amin o'hara slams monty williams and i
said slam
slams where are you guys from i you
don't know what flames are
do you think that was a plan no we're
actually gonna get a dunk tank out here
outside the rich eisen studios just for
you i mean so the next time you're in
town we appreciate you spending some
time buddy
thanks guys nino hassan joins the show
cinephobe podcast
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here